in this capsule we will introduce the
reinforcement learning concept
so the goals in this part of
short it may be necessary
firstly the first algorithms
learning necessarily takes one goes
to say passive we will end up on the most
delay still see three methods
different that are part of the
category of algorithms
learning parents inevitably passive
then we will go to algorithms
learning parents necessarily active
and we will see different methods
we're going to have four different ones
see here finally we will talk about the
dilemma of exploration versus
exploitation which is a very dilemma
important in learning not
reinforcement and finally we're going
discuss the problem of generalizing well
in the context of a certified
learning by reinforcement then
what kind of problem are we going to succeed
solve with parents learning
necessarily one of the first problem is
that of learning an intelligence
artificial for a game so we have a
example here of a backgammon game and one
will see later that actually with
learning by inevitably we have
managed to develop intelligences
artificial very good for the game of
bagad men we've already seen algorithms
to do learning in
context of two opponents game we have
saw the mini max algorithm then
alphabetic and a little more efficient and
learning parents inevitably we will
succeed in getting algorithms yet
more effective at learning to play at
a game like that being able to be a
good player a game is in too much
this approach there parents learning
necessarily your data from players who
can make decisions
typically faster but more
it's going to be a player who is going to be in
able to learn from
party simulations in a game without
have to define everything the graph of the
the result of the different actions in
in a game like we have to do
for mini max or alfa beta hello this
that we will succeed in doing is learning
to have an artificial intelligence
in a real environment
we have an example here of a controller
of helicopters which so this is a
artificial intelligence that controls
an island remotely controlled sensors then who has
learned to actually control the sensor
to do an inverted flight like this and
so we're really talking about one
brings a little closer to robotics
we really have an agent who is
deploys in a real world to see
that with learning necessarily
these kinds of problems that we will succeed
to solve
in fact there are several works on the
people's development 'artificial
in this context where we have a helicopter
it's learning to do different things
maneuvering the acrobatic with a cape
remote controlled town what kind of things we
will be able to do also with
learning not reinforcement ok
why we need learning not
strengthening almost everything we've seen
learning super factories which who
allows a calendar to take a certain
behavior and we saw that
learning supervise actually for
execute a learning grid
lost we need to give labeled
so data that comes from a
expert who tells another model what
must be his behavior in
different situations
so if we wanted to have in the junta
and people who play chess well
what should be done has begun
data where we would have an entry that
would be the state of the game then a disciple to
predict who would be the movement where
the action to do it in my game
chess in which room moved on
should collect either ideally from a
expert to have an agent who would
comparable to an expert but lies
that started this data there is a
work that is very tedious
several possibilities for the state of the
game so it makes a lot a lot of
data to collect to get a
player who behaves well and who plays
good at chess and so that's
a lot of time so
many of the high costs in terms
to ask an expert who should
save a lot of time
to give us his provides these
data to the tax authorities preferred this is
have an agent who will teach him to
from the result two parts that
the agent will play himself a bit like
we with
we learn well played a game by doing
several parties of supporters
basically practice a game so
it's true an agent who if he wins a
part will realize so his full his
politics so his behavior in
the environment for this game there is good
but that six toddlers who wants to achieve
that some weaknesses in his way
to play then who will try to
adapt according to the outcome of the
part and that's basically what
learning does not necessarily
will try to do that's how it is
is basically worth working so
learning parents inevitably goes
try to learn from
reward we see sometimes called
also a reinforcement so six
rewards that says that if they play
such way I speak the part if
Juicy rotations I lose the game
or six jousting such way I'm I'm going
orient myself to a position the part
which is good if dead is so we are going
see one way to specify these
reinforce the water on do you
cheeks well where do you play badly at
inside an algorithm
reinforcement learning
learning a scent will be done
a bit like an animal that perceives
negative rewards like pain
or hunger as part of a game this
would be right there maybe the frustration
pearls then positive so the pleasure or
if we talk about the animal that moves
in vain then who is sure so will
eat among others popper have
energy for to survive
and in this case as low we expect
what an animal want to maximize
rewards there is somehow
it's this kind of process there that
learning parents necessarily is
to simulate and then imitate to obtain
intelligent agents
we've already seen algorithms based on
decision processes marking well
then the editions editions mare that comes
you come here know your concept
important in learning by
reinforcement so they will try to
find an optimal plan to maximize
precisely a sum of reward so
the sum of the rewards we hoped we saw
to the 8 regions
we saw by the region but all these
algorithms requires knowledge
total of the transition model in my
environment
so this probability that if I'm a
state and that's what I do that I do
the action that I arrive at a new state
expresses so we need to specify
all these distributions there for
execute the region cure where valid
two very expensive policemen and we have
also need the function of
reinforcement therefore by cons in a
real environment
more often than not we can not
make the site a good model of
transition like that a priori we do not have
good definition of pds prims has and
so its robotic robot vacuum that gets
moves into a room but goes to
the real environment then that for a
review on tactics or a piece
whoever does not yet know the
piece so he has to learn made it the
configuration of helped the piece seen from
rare objects tracks
at the beginning we did not make this model of
transition the same thing for an agent
who controls a sensor so that's
very difficult to define these boxes
that happens if one sensor is in a
certain spatial position and that
I'm applying some control over good
my controller that will control and the
remote control sensor so what is going
arrive at the new position
the new configuration of the capa is
very difficult to hold alone a priori
and then even for games that are
totally cimic are on computer
like super mario get to a
definition of this model is an exercise
which is very complex
after lyon we would actually not like
having to do that can have a
algorithm that is capable
finally to discover what is this
transition model there basically
that's what learning by the
form only does it will aim to
find an optimal plan like with ben
ali to the scheme by the situation but without
we have to know has specified the
transition model for my
environment in which money gets
so definitely definitely mean
that's somehow
learning will necessarily be a
somehow the purest form
learning in intelligence
artificial
actually we have a little like
any living being an act that
moves in the environment that
accumulates reinforcement signal
positive or negative
and all the money has to do is
maximize these reinforcements while they
should be related to the fact that survival
not so somehow
actually it may be one of
most fearful forms this is also one of
forms of learning that is the most
difficult so is still a lot
a lot of research work in
learning by reinforcement is
so still a lot of way to go
to have an agent who makes it in
any environment capable
to learn to behave well
but we will see some algorithms
in the next capsules on how
to make some progress towards a
learning not learning
general reinforcement in one who is learning
well a given environment
and if we go back to the concepts of
of agen so in fact here in an agent
utility based one tries to maximize a
utility that is derived from the reinforcements
we're going to see the utility
corresponds to the strengthening con
the cumulative agent but in that if we get
finds in the context of an agent where he
does not know a priori comment on what
the world evolves and then comment on what
these actions will have an impact on his
next and to ok so we see some
algorithms that will try to learn
this part of the agent this part
there that our agent use for
learn to behave